stiva it's lovely to see you here at
collect ammonia today - enjoying the
weekend I've loved my weekend I've loved
being here some fabulous crowd and I
just always have fun when I travel to
new places and do new things and meet
new people I notice that you've been
cast in the second season of the
leftovers yes yes I've just joined the
cast as a recurring character and and
it's quite interesting for me I've been
reading a few of the scripts the scripts
of like fabulous to read and I'm playing
a little old guy with some mystery to
him we don't know who he is what he's
about you know it's sort of like my
x-files character mr. X but but much
older [ __ ] you know with a different
twist so I'm really really excited about
learning about this guy and about who he
is and where it's going take the left
over this is actually based on a book a
novel by Tom Perrault sir
was that something you're aware of when
he took on the part no it was not
something I was aware of that the book
was written by we saw his name Tom -
brother
yeah and Tom I think I met Tom they Tom
wrote one of the episodes that I've done
so I was not aware of the book I have
spent a great deal of my time being
unaware
like I was not I was unaware when I did
x-files how popular that show was I was
unaware of Supernatural when I joined
supernatural you know which may have
helped me in developing some of these
characters because sometimes we can get
over-involved and overact and sort of
you know you have too much information
going on and try to formulate too much
stuff in our heads and when you go in
naturally with not a lot of information
cluttering your brain sometimes you can
clearly portray a character much better
so I'm having a good time with this now
we've got a revival of the x-files what
did you think about that when you heard
about it I'm always I like the show
x-files and I and I loved my character
of mr. X I have not been invited to be a
part of the revival yet I'm hoping that
changes again because I love that
character I thought it was a very very
rich character I was disappointed when
he was killed off because of the
richness
of the character and the talent of the
writers I think it had a cadre of very
wonderful writers and I just thought
there was so much more to explore with
this guy and so much excitement and
mystery in this guy I would like the
opportunity to explore some more of that
so we'll see what happens after you died
in the original series of the x-files he
came back again didn't you soon I did
come back at the final I think it was
the final episode where we do a recap
and all of that stuff via X was there
again and that was exciting you know and
it was exciting to be reunited again
with mr. Kim manners who passed on God
rest his soul but since he was the guy
who brought me aboard and and and he was
also the guy who directed me in my debut
episode of Jump Street and he directed
me in my final episode of x-files and he
was one who brought me to Supernatural
you know so that was probably one of the
most exciting things about that that
final episode that final appearance is
mr. X you know and reuniting with the
gang man a lot of the gang I loved Mitch
I absolutely adore Mitch leggy and and
and he and I both showed up in
Supernatural together which I thought
was an absolute gasps and I hope the
fans enjoyed that shows that are very
popular they have supernatural has a
very big dedicated audience fanbase
isn't it the x-files have very big
dedicated fanbase what's that like for
you joining something like that as an
actor and being part of that family that
world well it's it's real exciting it's
real fun it's I'm kind of proud of it I
all of these shows are kind of iconic
shows and I've been doing reeker I'm
sort of the recurring specialist you
know I do recurring shows in all of them
so it's just it's just fun it's just
exciting and fun and adventurous about
supernatural that you enjoyed being part
of the most oh just everything I enjoyed
playing with with Jim beavers you know
originally when I when I asked the
producers about what he was supposed to
be was supposed to be - grumpy old man
and your based on - grumpy old man but
Jim was doing grumpy old man so well I
did not want to compete with him as a
grumpy old man so you'll notice that
Rufus was a little bit lighter you know
and I think we play it off of each other
very very nicely the boys were
absolutely excellent they accepted me
with open arms it's some fascinating
characters in there Misha I absolutely
adore you know such a nice man and he
has such a wonderful sense of humor
he's a raunchy mark Shepard
you know just great people Kim Rhodes I
certainly appreciated her she's sort of
responsible for the continuation she
introduced me to her manager mr. Richard
Turner and and and it sort of revived
you know my my work schedule because I
was kind of you know falling a little
bit to the wayside so yeah I'm excited
that was excited about that you know and
that's a great show you know it's a
great show the boys are probably the
hottest thing in the world right now
because the women that show up
incredible take you up to see the boys
but and the boys I think I am I would
think there is I mean I mean Rufus is
not dead remember he's his bones haven't
been burned and salted so he's not
entirely gone yet
so that possibility is there and I'd
love that possibility cuz I got an image
of what he would come back like I have
the visual you know of what he would
look like I mean he's gone to where he's
gone when he comes back he's gonna look
a little bit different and I got the
perfect look for him just in case just
in case they asked me back and the
producers agree with what I want to come
back looking like you know it will
really be a big shock it's gonna be cute
though talking about earlier about
x-files coming back they revived what
would you like to see happen in x-files
what would you like to see it go I would
like to see X come back number one you
know and I and I can't possibly phantom
where it would go I just think it was
such a creative project you know Chris
harder and and the writers I mean where
do they get this information from where
do these I
is come from you know it fascinates me
as much as it fascinates the rest of the
public there is something going on in
the universe that we don't know about I
think we as human beings don't know
doodly-squat you know and so I'm curious
about everybody's opinion about what's
going on and a lot of that you know is a
fiction writers suppose it fiction
writers opinion about what's really
happening in this universe in this we're
who are we as beings you know what is
this existence about there are a lot of
questions to be answered there are a lot
of questions to be asked and I think
that's the most fascinating thing about
life period there's all those questions
that need to be asked I don't know what
the answers are I don't know that we'll
ever know what any of the answers are
but it's it's fun to ask lovely talking
to you thanks so much for your time
thank you guys for giving me this time
you